[Music]
foreign
over the last few months you had another
popular new trend has been gaining Steam
on Tick Tock although I didn't hear
about it until yesterday when I saw an
interesting video that conservative
commentator Lauren Chen had made on the
subject now it's strange that I would be
so behind the curve on this because as
you all know I'm usually very plugged in
I'm very with it up to date on all the
trends I think I'm known that way in any
case this fashionable new trend is
called the stay-at-home girlfriend
there's a buzzfeed article explains what
it's all about though perhaps it's
rather self-explanatory is what it says
the day-to-day life of Kendall K one of
tick tock's maligned stay-at-home
girlfriends appears in her viral videos
to be well fairly dull we're jealous her
glamorous non-employment doesn't seem to
entail much more than journaling
preparing healthy snacks and seeing an
occasional butterfly on Twitter people
say that she seems like she has been
lobotomized highly medicated or
generally unfulfilled her meticulous
self-care and fitness routines a symptom
of the spreading that girl aesthetic
have been compared compared to that of
American psycho's serial killer Patrick
Bateman parody videos abound but her
Slow Soft life resonated with many
instead of criticizing her lack of a
nine to five they related to the dream
of one day being rich enough to have a
do-nothing job we've long been on the
verge of a hustle culture Reckoning and
K is one post away from leading the
revolution is it possible some of these
critics were just jealous too
now there are apparently many videos on
Tick Tock of these stay-at-home
girlfriends showing what their sort of
day-to-day life is like here's a
sampling from The Tick tocker mentioned
in that article here it is
this is my day in the life as a
stay-at-home girlfriend I'm currently in
Vancouver so I'm in a new house which is
so fun and the first thing I do is take
my aloe shot I love having this on an
empty stomach and I take my greens
then I get straight to making Luke's
coffee because he's definitely a
caffeine first thing in the morning kind
of guy
I am adding some honey and cream and I
made these cookies yesterday so I'm
going to give him a couple of those to
eat with his coffee then I sit down and
do some journaling and some reading
and then I get to making myself a matcha
with some cinnamon and ground ginger and
then I add some cashew milk on top yum
then I do my skin care and my LED mask
and then some ice rolling
just love doing the longest skincare
routine in the morning
then I love to open all the blinds in
the house and get all the sunlight I can
and make the bed of course to keep the
house tidy and looking its best
then it's time to make some breakfast
I've been loving these oats lately well
you probably get the idea they're
actually her morning routine is a lot
like mine
um you know I Stumble out of the out of
uh my room and I'm like uh just barely
awake and my kids try to talk to me and
say don't don't talk to me until I have
my aloe shot in Greens
and do my skincare routine with the ice
roller whatever that is uh no actually
that doesn't happen but at least the
part where she makes coffee I can relate
to that the rest of it not so much but
uh as the BuzzFeed piece alluded to not
everyone is on board with the
stay-at-home girlfriends uh as is always
the case with a tick tock Trend there
has a risen a competing trend of videos
explaining why the other trend is deeply
problematic problematic and critics are
primarily concerned that stay-at-home
girlfriends are living a terribly
unfeminist life having deprived
themselves of the empowerment and glamor
of the cubicle in favor of living under
the misogynistic tyranny of a boyfriend
who provides for their every need
according to these critics you know a
woman is is supposed to put on a
pantsuit and go to work and climb the
corporate ladder
a life that is so famously liberating
and enriching to the soul
she's certainly not meant to be at home
meanwhile other critics have decided
that it is of course racist to be a
stay-at-home girlfriend here's user
fazioli breadstick explaining this logic
reminded me of a threat
you should definitely pause and read her
take on it once again I just want to
reiterate that it's not my business or
anybody else's for that matter what you
choose to do whether you work or don't
work and let me be very clear that when
I'm talking about the stay-at-home
girlfriend Trend I'm not talking about
how other cultures divide labor in the
household rather I am talking about the
very recent cultural phenomenon in which
white women in particular romanticize
the idea of opting out of Labor that is
otherwise delegated to lower income
people and people of color what do
videos like these tell you about a who
gets to rest B who deserves rest and see
how you get rest I find it interesting
that in these videos nobody is calling
these women lazy or gold diggers in fact
most of them are concerned that they're
being taken advantage of when you look
at most social movements and political
movements upper white middle class women
are nowhere to be found because if they
wanted to create meaningful social
change they could they choose not to
because it goes against their class
interests they're my drop by
right no one is calling these women lazy
or gold diggers except for all the
thousands of people who are calling them
exactly that this is very common on the
left they'll often declare you know when
white people do fill in the blank nobody
criticizes them for it yet in reality
everyone criticizes them for it
including the person claiming they're
not being criticized for it
indeed the truth is the other way around
usually if it was primarily black women
making a stay-at-home girlfriend videos
then you wouldn't be allowed to
criticize it
but in this case Miss breadstick seems
to be arguing that because so many
racial minorities are not able to opt
out of the labor force white women
shouldn't opt out either they must be
allies they must make their lifestyle
decisions based on what other people are
doing
they're not allowed to be happy because
that would be unfair to all of the
racial minorities who Miss breadstick
assumes are not happy
this is allyship and here allyship
specifically means apparently getting a
job in the service industry even if you
don't need it or want it
which only means that you'll be taking a
position away from someone potentially
racial minority who does need it and
want it so I don't think that Miss
breadstick has thought this all the way
through
but these criticisms are all you know of
course extremely stupid
it may be unfeminist to become a
stay-at-home girlfriend but there's
nothing wrong with being unfeminist on
the contrary that's the lane that any
woman should want to be in considering
that feminists are also resentful and
miserable
if you don't know which way you want to
go in life uh and you're a woman you you
could do worse than simply just looking
at whatever feminists are doing and
heading in the exact opposite direction
it's also obviously not racist to live
your own life how you want to live it
you're not morally required to conduct a
racial inventory before making every
decision in your life and even if you
did conduct the inventory there there's
no point to it because according to the
left it's racist for a white person to
do things that black people aren't doing
but it's also racist to do things that
they are doing
so there's no sense in playing a game
that you can't win uh and and that's why
all these uh criticisms are ridiculous
but here's a criticism
of the state home girlfriend Trend that
is not ridiculous
the real problem
with the stay-at-home girlfriend
lifestyle is not the stay-at-home part
it's the girlfriend part
the problem of course is that these
women aren't married that's the issue
what this trend actually represents is a
is a broader Trend uh in a continued
attempt by many people in our culture to
figure out a way to enjoy the benefits
of marriage without actually getting
married
so many young people and young couples
they seek to take on the form of a
married relationship mimic it but
without the substance of the marriage
they're playing house they're playing
pretend
and that's where this trend truly
becomes to use the less favorite term
problematic
that's what you actually see in that
video it is it is a a woman is just like
it's it's house your playing house
that is a more sophisticated game of
house
the problems here are many but we will
um briefly focus on just one
you know both the stay-at-home
girlfriend and the working boyfriend
have made themselves incredibly
vulnerable here
and they've set themselves up for and
nearly inevitable and inevitably messy
and heartbreaking split
because the girl is relying on the guy
entirely to subsidize her lifestyle
relying on him to bring home the bacon
and bring home everything else too and
yet the one thing she doesn't have from
him the one thing he's not providing
even if she seems to have everything
else is any sort of meaningful
commitment
she is leaning on him completely but he
can just step to the side at any moment
and send her crashing to the floor
he hasn't even promised not to do that
he hasn't so much as promised not to
step to the side
indeed by not marrying her he has
promised that eventually he will abandon
because that's the whole reason why you
refuse to get married to someone is
because you want to leave your you want
to leave that escape hatch in place
a refusal to commit is a commitment of
its own you are committing to Breaking
Up Down the Line eventually
and when that day comes you know the the
breakup of this non-committed
effectively meaningless relationship
will be very messy and difficult much
more messy and difficult than a breakup
between boyfriend and girlfriend ought
to be because normally dumping your
girlfriend should require no more than
one awkward conversation and that's it
you go your separate ways and you never
have to speak to each other again
if you don't want to that's the way it
should go if you're just dating someone
that's the whole point of dating that's
one of the things that's supposed to
separate it from marriage is that you're
not in really entangled in any way you
just you're living your own lives you're
dating and if you want to live one life
together that's why you get married
now the great thing is that if you're
not if you're living separate lives and
then you decide that okay we're not
going to get married this isn't going to
work out just go your separate ways
that's it
you'll be sad about it for a while but
you'll get over it
once you've added houses and mortgages
into the mix
then when you when you've taken on many
of the obligations and shared roles of a
marriage even though you aren't married
you end up with a breakup that feels and
looks an awful lot like a divorce
so
you never had the benefit of the
marriage
but you still get the crap storm of the
divorce
it's the worst of all worlds
and then the guy in this Arrangement is
no bet is in no better shape he's
working every day and providing for a
woman who has made no commitment to him
he has taken on a dependent and yet
still has no wife
he is a man with no wife no children no
marriage no family and yet still has a
dependent that he's taken care of every
day
you know there's that crass expression
often used to describe a man with a
living girlfriend they say well you know
he's getting the milk for free so why
buy the cow
but the truth is that he's the cow in
this scenario he's being used by a woman
who again has made no promises to him no
commitment no oath of fealty
she could be spending part of her ample
free time every day in bed with some
other guy she met at the gym or whatever
and she wouldn't even be violating any
vow by doing so because no vow was ever
made
the guy can't even say you broke your
promise I Never Promised anything to you
not officially
we couldn't even call it an affair
because they aren't married so it's not
an affair
she would be cheating yes but cheating
what an ambiguous relationship where no
official promises or commitments have
ever been made
so what
this is why if you want to enjoy a
relationship that looks and acts like a
marriage there is no substitute for
actually getting married no matter how
desperately our culture looks for a
substitute it's just not there
and that is why even after defending
these stay-at-home girlfriends from some
of their especially stupid critics I
must still say that the state home
girlfriends are
unfortunately canceled although they
could just graduate to being stay at
home wives and mothers and then that
would be a whole other story entirely
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]